this quote that comes from pipple I love
this quote and I love this about you and
I love this about Cuban Americans you
said to whoever the [__] doesn't like
the United States of America may God
bless you but [__] you at the same time
yeah if you don't like the United States
of America go back to the countries
you're the [__] from and see how you
appreciate the United States of America
absolutely you see you came from Cuban
refugees yes I came from a father who
said to me daily the reason we love
America there's opportunity these people
have never lived anywhere else they
don't know how [__] up it is in other
countries there's no Freedom yes your
your parents lived under Castro yeah
the biggest scumbag on the [__]
planet basically imprisoned the people
of Cuba it's still a prison it's still a
prison yeah yeah they can't get out from
under for one any opportunity that I get
I make sure that the United States of
America stays the United States of
America not the divided States of
America right politics I call it
politics yeah so for me I only deal with
politicians when I need to and more than
anything it's for education in the
schools have you ever endorsed a
candidate or you've never no the only
one that I actually went to speak but I
wasn't endorsing I just appreciated the
fact that he gave me a chance to speak
about my story was actually Barack Obama
if you see when I speak I'm just saying
hey I just want to say thank you for
giving me an opportunity to speak about
my journey my life and how beautiful
United States of America has been to us
and our family it wasn't hey go vote for
this person no not at all I steer clear
but I'm always in tune you certainly
understand the value of America and
immigration I mean you got your shot in
this country because you were give your
parents were given an opportunity to
come over to this country and you you
like to see other people get a break
people want to absolutely I mean that's
what this hope this country is about
right the United States of America is
built by immigrants and if you really
we're all immigrants yes
thanks
foreign